d'abord Erwan balanon Macron Emmanuel
Macron qui persiste et qui signe est-ce
que vous adhérez à ce qu'il a dit à
cette position aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes à fond derrière lui alors
j'adhère pas l'idée qu'il persiste et
qui signe d'accord pourquoi parce que
moi j'ai vu un certain nombre
d'inflexion des inflexions sur la
question fiscale d'abord il l'a dit il a
dit qu'il fallait revoir la fiscalité
des très grandes entreprises qui
faisaient des grands profits ou des
grands bénéfices donc moi pour moi il y
a un changement et puis moi je l'espère
et je l'appelle de mes vœux et je lui en
ai parlé hier dans les courts échanges
qu'on a pu avoir que la question de la
justice fiscale et la justice sociale
soient remise en avant dans ce pays on a
le président Macron a réussi une
première partie de de son premier
quinquennat et cette première année sur
sur la question de la gestion de la
crise la gestion des crises la gestion
économique du pays le pays
économiquement objectivement il va bien
au regard des crises qui nous secouent
le plein emploi on s'y approche et les
Français aujourd'hui ont besoin de
sentir que cet effort qui a eu lieu et
il a eu lieu pour les Français ça a été
difficile pour les Français soit partagé
et moi je note
qu'on montre aux Français que ils ont
fait un effort et qu'on remercie
expliquer que la réforme des retraites
il la faisait pas de gaieté de cœur et
j'aurais peut-être aimé d'ailleurs qu'on
l'entende le dire plus tôt parce que ça
aurait peut-être aussi permis une
meilleure compréhension
sur le 49-3 je partage je fais partie
des députés qui ont trouvé qu'on aurait
dû aller au vote qu'il fallait aller au
vote alors après
une obstruction comme jamais des
attitudes inadmissibles d'une partie de
l'opposition et ça je crois que personne
n'en sort gagnant le président
l'exécutif nous députés de la majorité
et les fauteurs de troubles de la LFI
c'est dommage parce que on aurait pu
avoir un vrai débat parle enterré on l'a
pas lu on l'a pas eu et c'est et c'est
vous avez raison et c'est un et c'est un
vrai problème parce que dans une
démocratie le Parlement ça doit être le
cœur battant de la démocratie vous
auriez aussi pu voter s'il y avait pas
eu l'utilisation du 49-3 là dessus
Emmanuel Macron pardon de le dire de
cette manière et je réutilise la formule
mais il persister ici il a pas dit je
regrette d'avoir utilisé le 49-3 puisque
évidemment il y avait des chances que
cette réforme ne passe pas est-ce que
là-dessus au moins vous qui vous y allez
au vote vous vous dites pas quand même
là on a mal joué notre coup je crois que
sur l'ensemble de la conduite de cette
réforme on va pas dire qu'on a réussi on
va pas dire que c'est une victoire je
crois que ça serait complètement être
sourd aux préoccupations des Français
d'une part parce que moi j'entends les
préoccupations des Français et c'est
pour ça que je souhaite qu'on embraye et
que très vite on attaque à la question
on s'attaque à la question du travail
dans notre pays des pénibilités des
rythmes de travail du partage de la
valeur
il faut le faire mais ou non c'est pas
c'est pas une victoire effectivement
nous nous avons pas était très bon sur
cette réforme c'était évident
je souris un peu en entendant les
députés RN qui nous disent qu'ils vont
se battre à tout prix enfin ils ont ils
ont été complètement absents des débats
le peu de débats qui a eu ils avaient
quasiment pas d'amendements des
amendements qui étaient bon enfin
franchement c'est quoi ce qui propose et
c'est OK rien il propose la retraite à
60 ans
j'ai rien compris alors système 60 ans
pour ceux qui ont commencé à moins à 20
ans et puis ensuite plus ce qui fait
qu'en réalité ça fait plus d'annuité que
pour les Français aujourd'hui donc c'est
pas sérieux leur projet il est pas
sérieux à ce stade qui continue à
travailler et nous on continuera à nous
battre contre les idées qu'il véhicule
qui sont pas des idées satisfaisantes
pour la France j'aime bien le redire
aussi est-ce que dans la majorité
présidentielle tout le monde est
toujours main dans la main l'esprit
libre cheveux au vent et tout roule
c'est pas gentil de parler de mes
cheveux non
un petit peu compliqué non mais alors
contrairement à ce qu'on est enfin vous
êtes assez caricaturaux parce que quand
on est dans une position comme au mandat
précédent on était tous soi-disant des
Playmobil mais non il y avait déjà du
débat à ce moment-là il y a déjà parfois
des tensions sauf qu'on les règle entre
nous et même aujourd'hui il y a des
c'est pas des tensions c'est le débat
démocratique c'est c'est des différences
qui doivent s'exprimer mais il y a quand
même un projet commun le projet commun
c'est de faire en sorte que la France
réussisse que la France se développe que
la France atteigne le plein emploi et
garde ce modèle qui a un modèle que
beaucoup nous envie de ce que j'appelle
la mutualisation du risque sur la
sécurité sociale l'école gratuite etc la
majorité présidentielle aujourd'hui
n'est pas abîmée ou fissuré à cause de
ce qu'on a pu voir sur la réforme des
retraites on disait de la majorité
notamment des députés qu'ils étaient
sonnés après l'utilisation du 49-3 on en
a déjà parlé ensemble et on va pas y
revenir mais est-ce que ça ça n'a pas
créé une difficulté au sein de vos rangs
non mais ce qui est difficile
aujourd'hui il faut l'admettre c'est de
faire des une réforme qui est
particulièrement difficile contraignante
pour les Français donc c'est pas facile
notre position oui mais moi j'ai été élu
sur un programme avec un projet avec
l'idée d'aller vers le plein emploi avec
l'idée de de faire un certain nombre de
réalisations pour la France et et on y
va et on va continuer mais moi je le dis
et je l'affirme il faut qu'on reste à
l'écoute et on peut rester à l'écoute
s'il y a pas trop de violence dans notre
pays parce que ça c'est un vrai sujet et
vraiment moi je suis ouvert je continue
à dialoguer avec les habitants de ma
circonscription évidemment est-ce que
vous appelez de vos vœux Erwan banana
des négociations avec les syndicats ou
des concertations on parlait de
l'importance des mots là ça l'est
notamment ah mais il faut que dans ce
pays on se réconcilie avec les syndicats
c'est évident moi je salue l'attitude
des syndicats pendant toute la période
et jusqu'à maintenant encore sur
l'encadrement des manifestations le
travail qui a été fait moi par exemple
j'ai été reçu par l'intersyndicale de
mon territoire ça s'est passé
cordialement on a pu discuter ça m'a
même nourri pour justement cette loi
travail et moi je souhaite continuer ce
travail et le dialogue social dans notre
pays le travail par branche aussi parce
que les branches ont des situations
différentes c'est fondamental avec un
mon sens 4 priorités redonner un sens au
travail se dire c'est quoi travailler
pourquoi on travaille qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui guide le travail qu'on a
et c'est pas pareil pour tous les
métiers le rythme du temps de travail
peut-être que le rythme du temps de
travail et le volume horaire ou le
volume hebdomadaire n'a pas être le même
en début de carrière quand on a des
enfants dans une période où on a plus de
temps et puis au moment de de du temps
où on est un peu plus âgé la question de
pénibilité conditions de travail
évidemment et le dernier point qui est
aussi un point cardinal pour moi le de
la valeur et les salaires la question
des salaires aujourd'hui il y a trop de
métiers qui ne gagnent pas assez bien
leur vie partage de la valeur sur lequel
les syndicats enfin les partenaires
sociaux ce sont déjà mis dans ce sont
déjà accordés je suis frappé malgré tout
par le temps passe sur très rapidement
non il y a encore des crises la crise en
Ukraine n'est pas finie et on va avoir
adressons mais je pense que le président
n'a pas ménagé s'attache sur la question
de l'Ukraine enfin et puis c'est pas lui
que ça se voit pas tellement à
l'intérieur on en débat pas je sais
qu'il a beaucoup de qualité beaucoup de
talents mais c'est pas lui qui va faire
l'appel à lui tout seul donc voilà et
sur la question de la crise climatique
on a aussi un sujet et moi c'est un
sujet sur lequel j'essaye de travailler
et de porter aussi une voix